surprise it's totally not Mark very
literally this time um I'm AJ one of his
staff members I was tasked with drawing
this kid Goku from the daer trailer as
not just an adult but also in the style
of the series character designer KATU
Yosi nakatsuru that's a pretty hard ask
there's like 4 million examples of his
modern work through illustration but
there's not a whole lot of him actually
doing animation so I kind of had to like
put a hodg podge of references together
to try and get something that sort of
looked about right I'm mostly focused on
getting the shapes right and I noticed
that his illustrations have like 4
million layers of shading but if you
pull up some of the animated stuff he's
done he doesn't really do that at all
and so I dialed it right back kind of
like the original except adding a little
bit more than that just because it's a
more serious adult Goku I messed up the
eyes at first please do not do a before
and after it looks so bad but overall I
think once that was fixed once it was
colored and got composited I think it
turned out pretty nice and I hope you
like it too